عزيز رعب يحوم في الاجواء مجددا
مسيره انتحاريه عبرت فوق ميدان الاستقلال
وسط العاصمه الاوكرانيه بالتزامن مع
انفجارات لم تهدا
قضت مضاجع السكان فهرعوا الى الملاجئ قبل
ان تعترضها الدفاعات الجويه في محيط القصر
الرئاسي
لكن مسيره اخرى كان قصفها اكثر قوه
صور التقطها احد سكان احياء كياف اظهرت
اثار الهجوم الجديد بثماني عشره مسيره كما
قالت السلطات الاوكرانيه هجوم احدث اثرا
بالغا في ممتلكاتي كما في نفوس
الاوكرانيين
هذا هو الاستهداف الحادي عشر منذ بدايه
شهر مايو ما يعني انهم يهاجموننا كل ليله
تقريبا هذه لم تعد حربا هذا اصبح عملا
ارهابيا بحقنا
اضرار ماديه لحقت باحياء مختلفه في
العاصمه نجمت ايضا عن حطام المسيرات التي
تقول السلطات انها اسقطتها جميعا لكنه
وصولها الى مناطق سكنيه وتجاريه قد يعني
اختراقها للدفاعات المحيطه بالمدينه ما
يزيد من الضغط على السكان
ما يجري مؤلم للغايه هذا مصدر رزق الوحيد
وقد تعرض لاضرار لا يمكن اصلاحها لكن
للروس راي اخر لا اعلم ما علينا فعله الان
هي معركه مفتوحه مع الدفاعات الجويه براي
المسؤولين العسكريين الذين ينتظرون تعزيز
قدراتها بالطائرات الحربيه
يريدون ان يهاجموا مراكز صنع القرار في
بلدنا ومنظومات دفاعاتنا الجويه
واستنزافها عبر هذه الهجمات الموسعه لكننا
نتصدى لهم ونعلم ان شركائنا سيزودوننا
بالمزيد منها وربما كذلك بالطائرات
الحربيه التي ستساعد دفاعاتنا الجويه
ظن سكان العاصمه هذه المشاهد باتت من
الماضي لكن الهجمات المكثفه اعادتها الى
الاذهان رغم مرور اكثر من عام على الحرب
وسط تحضيرات من استنزاف الدفاعات الجويه
الاوكرانيه ما قد يجعل الخطر على العاصمه
اكبر واقرب حسن مسعود الجزيره كييف